[Applaudissements]
Justin Trudeau tente de faire une entrée
remarquée il n'avait pas l'intention de
se présenter les mains vides je suis
très heureux d'être avec vous
aujourd'hui pour resserrer les liens
déjà très forts entre les Canadiens et
les populations de l'Asie du Sud-Est le
Premier ministre annonce un
investissement de 330 millions de
dollars sur 50 destinés à ces 10 pays de
l'Asie Pacifique aide au développement
protection des océans commerces le
Canada tente de prouver le sérieux de
son engagement dans la région et faire
oublier une présence inégale ces
dernières années le Canada va continuer
d'être là en tant que partenaire fiable
c'est association de 10 pays dont le
Vietnam l'Indonésie et les Philippines
connaîtra une croissance phénoménale au
cours des prochaines années le Canada a
bien l'intention d'en profiter et à
entamer des négociations de
libre-échange avec le groupe l'année
dernière
parle de progrès important dans les
pourparler sans spécifier d'échéancier
le Canada n'est pas le seul pays à
courtiser la région
le président américain a fait le détour
il annonce des partenariats en matière
de véhicules électriques notamment
de la rhétorique déclare du Biden le
Canada et les États-Unis cherche à
freiner la puissance grandissante de la
Chine dans la région pour nous la chaîne
était une puissance mondiale qui était
perturbatrice la nouvelle stratégie
Indo-Pacifique du Canada adopte une
posture plus ferme face à Pékin Mélanie
Joly ne crée pas les représailles même
si le Canada tente de conclure des
ententes dans l'arrière cours de la
Chine
donc il y a pas de surprise les cartons
sur la table et notre objectif est
d'être président dans la région le
Canada peut agir avec assurance quand il
sait que les États-Unis sont assez cotés
cette complicité devrait aussi se faire
sentir au sommet du G20 cette semaine on
est Indonésie ou le gouvernement Trudeau
promet de tout faire pour isoler la
Russie à la suite de son évasion Ukraine
ici Louis Blouin Radio-Canada Phnom Pen
au Cambodge